well on every one of my social media
feeds for the last five days or four
days since this article hit people have
been exploding their brains are frying
out of their heads over this article in
The Wall Street Journal Mike Maru has 1
million dollars in student loans how did
this happen
Mike Maru a 37 year old orthodontist
made a big investment in his education
and as of Thursday he owed 1 million
sixty thousand nine hundred and
forty-five dollars in student loans mr.
Murrow pays only fifteen hundred and
eighty nine dollars a month not enough
to even cover the interest so his debt
seven years from seven years at the
University of Southern California grows
up by a hundred and thirty dollars a day
in two decades his loan balance will be
two million dollars he and his wife
Melissa have become numb to the burden
focused instead on raising their two
daughters if you thought about it every
single day mr. Murrow said you'd have a
mental breakdown due to escalating
tuition and easy credit the US now has
101 people who owe at least a million
dollars in federal student loan debt
five years ago is 14 people while the
typical student Morrow arose seventeen
thousand that's not true it's 37 the
number of those who owe at least one
hundred thousand has risen to two and a
half million the government essentially
allows graduate students to borrow any
amount to cover tuition and living costs
with few guardrails on how the final sum
will be repaid these are choices we are
not coercing that says the Dean of usc's
Herrmann Ostrow School of Dentistry or
mr. Murrow went to school this is one of
the most expensive dental schools in the
US you know exactly what you're getting
into says the Dean dental school is the
cost list of higher education programs
in the US and an average of seventy one
thousand eight hundred twenty dollars a
year
the USC program now costs ninety one
thousand dollars a year one hundred and
thirty seven thousand when living
expenses are included halfway through
dental school he said he started worried
about the soaring cost of his education
take half way you're in the most
expensive dental school in the u.s. I'm
sitting here saying holy crap should I
really be doing this mr. Marui called
should I drop out mr. Marui 35 said her
husband and her decided it was too late
to turn back if he quit her transferred
to a cheaper school he's still owed for
the loans he already had yeah so the
cheaper school would keep you from doing
what the USC education helped mr. Murrow
earn twenty five thousand last year no
being a dentist helped him earn two and
twenty five thousand if you're working
for a corporate practice in Draper Utah
outside Salt Lake City that compares
with one hundred and fifty eight
thousand median income for dentists some
dental school educators fear that the
eye-popping
let me help you all the set for a second
that's a Miss that's a misnomer they
stop just for a second um the median
income for dentists is one hundred fifty
eight thousand but not for orthodontists
and he's north of dontist so let's learn
the difference here it's 225 he's not
making extra money because he went to
USC where he went to school did not
increase his income he went to the most
expensive school and he makes an average
income note to those of you who want to
go to expensive school because you say
it's going to cause you to make more
money
it doesn't anyway moving on some dental
school educators fear that the
eye-popping costs to enter the
profession could this way good prospects
from even trying yeah think dental
schools financial aid director estimated
that the basic four-year program would
require four to five hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt
mr. Murrow and his wife concluded dental
school is a good investment we're like
well we can make this work yeah they'd
sense to me they took it out on a lower
interest rate long story short the
interest rate went up they got
themselves in trouble a law passed in
Congress in 2001 severed the link that
tethered student loan interest rates to
Treasury rates and the rates went up
causing him to get into a bigger mess
the one luxury I'm skipping along was
buying a used Mercedes Benz which
carries a payment of a three hundred
ninety dollars
the couple then bought a home using a
four hundred thousand dollar mortgage
mr. malroux took out in her name she
used an inheritance from her grandfather
for the down payment
and her mother co-signed for the loan
because she's married to a broke dentist
mr. Marui then entered into a
government-sponsored repayment program
on the loan for after ten years as loan
will be forgiven but when you add up
everything he's paid in he will have
paid back a million dollars even by then
and then you and I will eat the other
million roughly since refinancing his
debt with the federal government in 2015
miss mr. Murray's balance has grown by
one hundred fifty thousand dollars it
will keep growing through the 25 year Oh
it's a 25 year life of the repayment
plan until it reaches 2 million the sum
will be forgiven and at current tax
rates will cost him another seven
hundred thousand dollars in income tax
for forgiveness of debt the government
repayment plan affords the Murray family
a comfortable life their home is on a
mountain with panoramic views of the
snow-capped peaks surrounding Salt Lake
City they take vacations including a
recent trip to Havana and they drive a
used Tesla yeah it doesn't make your
head explode extreme things like this
always do make the news and obviously
this is an extreme thing but what it
does point out is a whole bunch of
things one thing it points out is is
that you and I are stupid America we're
stupid because we elected to Congress
that allows a student loan program like
that to be in place because you and I
are getting ready to pay this guy's bill
these are federally insured student
loans the taxpayer ensures the student
loans no one else gives unlimited lines
of credit to 18 year olds on unsecured
debt except you and me
no banker in his right mind would give
this and bankers loan money like hot
potatoes they'll loan money to a dog
that's dead and they won't loan money to
you but now you and me we're so bright
we think the students you know college
education is so important and the whole
economy would collapse in America would
be a bunch of illiterates if we don't
step up and pay these if we don't step
up and insure these student loans so I'm
telling you you need to call your
Congressman based on this article right
here which wakes you up and say the
federally insured student loan thing
needs to stop you want to stop colleges
from overcharging it's real simple when
nobody goes there because there
frickin expensive their rates will drop
but when they have an unlimited supply
of money from the government insured by
stupid people like you and me and signed
up for stupid people like this guy who
didn't even add up what his costs were
gonna be until he was halfway through
this is a whole group of stupid people
in a pile stupid college is overcharging
stupid tax payers that are willing to
sign up willing to sign on for this guy
because you and I are gonna pay this
your tax money is paying this guy's bill
because we're stupid cuz only stupid
people own people like this money so
we're stupid we guaranteed this loan
it's a federally insured student loan
the student loan program is a freaking
disaster Mike murrow's life is a
disaster so Mike you're in Salt Lake
City my man you're in a hurt you're in a
world of hurt you become the
laughingstock of America after this
article I'm so sorry people are probably
writing him hate mail like crazy I'm not
gonna write your hate mail I'm not gonna
pile on I've done dumb things too if
you're within the sound of my voice and
in Salt Lake City I promise you you are
you get in touch with us we will help
you for free you will not like dr.
Dave's prescription for your life you're
getting ready to sell everything my man
and work like a maniac but I can
actually get you out of this mess
I'm probably the only one that can you
get in touch with me and I'll help you
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]